if you've been playing Assassin's Creed
origins these last few days than you
know it's all about that legendary gear
there are many ways to obtain legendary
and rare equipment but one way is
through the papyrus scrolls you find
scattered throughout Egypt these scrolls
contain hints as to where you can find
buried treasure and will always net you
a rare piece of equipment or better and
500 XP typically you can find these
Scrolls in temples or landmarks across
Egypt once you've entered a temple you
can hold the left stick in order to show
your location objectives if you see a
papyrus scroll hunt that down once you
have it check your inventory and
navigate to papyri here you can see the
scrolls you've collected and the hints
they have to offer sinew can't spot the
treasure so it's up to you and byuk to
follow their directions there are 25
caches to Luton all and if you're having
trouble here the locations for a long
drink fertile lands the stone gaze
deafening silence sea of sand divided
Valley dead-end and nature's way thank
you for watching and if you have any
tips on finding these treasures make
sure to leave a comment below
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you